governor andrew cuomo is holding an
event this morning where a pair of
health care workers are going to be
the first to receive the kovid 19
vaccines
during this live stream it's happening
right now we're going to dip in and take
a listen here
governor thank you so much and uh let me
also express
uh our thanks to you for your
extraordinary leadership during this
whole
pandemic over the last number of months
and obviously today
and the fact that you committed to
science and data to guide your
leadership is absolutely extraordinary
and as you said we're in eastern queens
and as you know queens was the epicenter
of the covet issue back a number of
months ago this is where
it hit the hardest and this facility in
long island jewish was right at the
center
and here at northwell you know we've
seen well over a hundred thousand covet
patients and at one point back in
april we had over 3500 patients in our
hospitals
and as you said we are the largest
health system in new york
and we are very very proud of our
frontline staff
and of course of the frontline staff of
all of the
and all of the hospitals and all of the
facilities across the region this
spectacular work and as you said they
are the real heroes
uh so it's a pleasure to be here uh with
sandra
and dr chester and i don't think we need
to delay any
further because this is a special moment
a special day
this is what everybody has been waiting
for uh
to be able to give the vaccine and to
hopefully
see see this is the the beginning of the
end of the covet issue
but i just would like to say something
though that just because we're giving
out the vaccine
is no excuse for the public out there
not to continue wearing masks
not the social distance etc you have to
continue to comply with safety standards
even though the vaccine is going to be
distributed over the
next couple of months we have to do both
if we're going to be successful here
as you know very well so again governor
we thank you
thank you for your extraordinary
leadership and with that
let me um turn it over to dr chester
and then um and with
sandra here hopes andre is a critical
care nurse
has been on the front lines all during
the the crisis
um is a director in critical care
she has seen a lot and
she is on very very happy to be here to
receive
the vaccine and dr chester is a director
of our employee health services
so with that dr chester will turn it
over to you
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
sandra you didn't you didn't flinch
i take it that dr chester so governor
andrew cuomo there is addressing
a healthcare worker at the long island
jewish medical center
sandra lindsey she's a critical care
nurse
at the health care center she is
obviously as you
just witnessed one of the first to
receive the pfizer vaccine since it
arrived for distribution
here in new york state the other person
that is about to be vaccinated the
second in new york state
is yves doriso md chair of emergency
medicine at lenox hill hospital what a
moment this is for the country and for
the world
of course andrew cuomo is highlighting
this moment but those that deserve this
moment
are those trace on the front lines who
have been
fighting this virus those that have
invented
and then finally tuned this virus going
through trial to trial
public public evaluation periods that
we've been waiting on and here it is
live happening long island new york
where two health care
professionals are among the first to
receive this vaccine let's
listen back into the nurse
and to not give up so soon
there is light at the end of the tunnel
but we still need to continue to wear
our land
to social distance i believe in science
as a nurse my practice is guided by
science
and so i trust time what i don't trust
is that if i contract hold it i don't
know how it's very fascinating
or those who i come in contact with so i
you said it very well sandra we trust
signs here in the state of new york
federal government approved the vaccine
we then have new york state have a
separate panel that also approved the
vaccine
and we've been following the science all
along uh
i hope this gives you uh and the health
care workers who are battling this every
day
uh a sense of security and safety and a
little more confidence in doing your job
once the second vaccine has been
administered
in new york we prioritized healthcare
workers at the top of the list to
receive the vaccine
because we know that you are out there
every day
putting your lives in danger for the
rest of us so we want to make sure we're
doing everything we can to keep you safe
and uh the point about
new yorkers and americans having to do
their part
and take the vaccine because the vaccine
only works if the american people take
it
they estimate we need 75 percent
to 85 percent of americans to take the
vaccine
for it to be effective uh so
every american has to do their part and
your point is right
it uh it's going to take months
before the vaccine hits critical mass
so this is the light at the end of the
tunnel
but it's a long tunnel and we need
people to continue to be
do the right thing in the smart thing
all through the holiday season
and hopefully when we get to about june
they estimate the the vaccine can hit
critical mass but
the health care workers will get it
first because we know
that you're super stressed during this
holiday season
so god bless you i want to thank you
from the bottom
of our hearts for what you do everybody
knows it
everybody knows how brave you are and
skilled
and talented and selfless
when they use the word heroes we don't
mean that lightly we mean it deeply and
sincerely
what you do showing up every day
you really are heroes and we wish you
and your families
a blessed holiday season michael downey
thank you very much for your leadership
once again my friend
yeah uh thank you god and uh we will
beat this
we will win thank you when my time comes
when my time comes i want dr chester i
like her style
no problem you want to be there
thank you guys thank you very much thank
you god
round of applause for those medical care
workers there
as you just heard the medical
professional we will
beat this what a moment that was the
first coronavirus vaccines trace being
administered right here in new york
state split screen with governor there
in albany
but then the two health care workers the
first to get it were at long island
jewish medical center and of course this
is one of the 44 new york city hospitals
that has that ultra cold storage
needed for the vaccine they said that
they wanted to be among the first they
want to fight the public
fear of this vaccine those health care
workers they have been on the front
lines the hospital says
through all 10 months of this pandemic
and one of them is quoted
saying it is their hope their
willingness to be among the first to
be vaccinated to serve as an example to
the general public to take advantage of
this life-saving treatment so
here here i think we're all very happy
and pleased to see what just happened